[Applaudissements]
24 avril 2022 le président candidat
Emmanuel Macron est réélu
et c'est peut-être une nouvelle histoire
qu'il tente d'écrire dès ce soir là
les photographes n'ont pas eu le choix
de l'endroit perché sur une tribune d'où
chacun sortira la première photo celle
de la victoire
Jean-Claude couteau est un habitué des
soirées électorales
merci chers amis ce soir au milieu des
autres ils cherchent la bonne image
celle qui demande fera la une du journal
Le Monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des présidents la Cinquième République
en a déjà connu cette autre de Gaulle
Pompidou Giscard d'Estaing Chirac
Sarkozy Hollande
chacun a tenté de laisser une trace et
une image de lui-même qui pourtant
souvent lui a échappé
[Musique]
fabriquer une image présidentielle est
un art subtil fragile ou tout est
question de réglage de lumière et d'une
chimie particulière
[Musique]
lorsque l'on développe une photo il faut
toujours tester le temps d'exposition à
la lumière pour obtenir l'image que l'on
souhaite
trop s'exposer c'est prendre le risque
de brûler son image mais ne pas
s'exposer assez c'est peut-être risquer
pire encore pour un homme politique
rester dans l'ombre
[Musique]
alors souvent les chefs d'État tonne
font des essais réajuste mais il y a
toujours quelque chose qui leur échappe
[Musique]
et l'image que nous nous faisons d'eux
au fil du temps n'est pas toujours celle
qu'ils avaient prévu
[Musique]
alain Genestar et journaliste patron de
presse et ancien directeur de la
rédaction de Paris Match
des photos d'hommes politiques il en a
publié beaucoup
il se consacre maintenant à polka sa
galerie et son magazine photo
pour des images toujours aussi
politiques
dans quelle mesure les photographes
participent à la fabrication de l'image
d'un président
s'appelle un photographe officiel ou si
c'est la conséquence de leur acte
photographique à partir du moment où
vous prenez une photo d'abord vous êtes
en mettre de ce qui va se passer devant
votre objectif surtout pour un homme
politique et encore plus pour un
président il a
vous n'avez pas le surprendre comme ça
donc déjà les circonstances de la photo
sont décidées par le personnage lui-même
ou son entourage
après un personnage politique joue un
rôle
ce que ce qu'on essaie de faire quand on
est photographes notamment quand on a
des photographes politiques c'est
d'essayer de gratter un peu la surface
pour connaître le personnage
[Musique]
Marc bruncourt j'ai été rédacteur en
chef photo à Paris Match pendant 37 ans
et
ma spécialité
au service photo de Paris Match c'était
un peu ce qu'on appelle un moment les
grands dossiers les grandes morts les
grands événements les anniversaires
choses comme ça voilà donc
une spécialité qui me fait plonger
systématiquement dans les Archives de
Paris Match
[Musique]
Paris Match le poids des mots le choc
des 15 millions de photos archivés
depuis sa création en 1938
et ben voilà
Paris Match et ces 3 millions et demi de
lecteurs par semaine c'est un passage
obligé pour à peu près tout homme
politique en course pour la présidence
des instants volés organisés familiaux
ou professionnels qui construisent peu à
peu l'image qui restera
[Musique]
une photo politique pour moi c'est pas
forcément une photo d'un homme qui a
angle à foule d'ailleurs un micro sur
une estrade ou
sur un plateau de télé pour moi la photo
politique c'est de ramener cette
personnalité politique homme femme
au plus près les Français de nos
lecteurs c'est à dire de faire descendre
de l'estral et qui nous emmène chez eux
pour que les gens s'identifient à ces
personnalités
les politiques savent depuis longtemps
combien ils ont besoin d'images pour
exister dans les années 50 René Coty est
le premier à ouvrir le bal des séances
photos de l'intimité d'un président
servis par sa femme ou en robe de
chambre
les photos n'ont rien de vraiment
naturel
[Musique]
le général de Gaulle lui accepte son
grand enthousiasme de faire entrer les
photographes pour une séance photo dans
son salon
mais quelques années plus tard Georges
Pompidou ouvre une nouvelle voie il sera
le premier à comprendre comment jouer
avec son image et avec les photos
journalistes
[Musique]
dans sa vie privée dans en tant que
candidat et après en tant que président
de la République et là vraiment on va
avoir des images qu'on a jamais vu comme
par exemple celle-ci c'est vraiment la
première fois qu'on assiste un conseil
des ministres on a Conseil des ministres
et hop le photographe continue à suivre
Georges Pompidou et là on est vraiment
dans sa vie quoi
donc on a ce président qui va chercher
le bois qui est en train d'alimenter son
feu de cheminée qui embrasse sa femme
avec ce petit-fils voilà et puis quand
Georges Pompidou va par exemple au fort
Branson et ben voilà il nous emmène et
il va sur un bateau sa femme est à côté
que Pompidou le photographier avec un
polaroid on est dans l'intimité dans les
vacances d'autres vacances encore
ça c'est quand même une série qui est
assez exceptionnelle c'est Georges
Pompidou à la pêche à la crevette avec
ses amis
voilà le titre c'était sur la côte
bretonne voici Georges entre guillemets
pêcheur de crevettes et ça les lecteurs
de matchs vont aimer ça
et quelle est la différence entre une
photo politique et une photo de
communication là il y a une frontière
évidemment souvent on va demander à
une femme politique de pas de rentrer un
peu dans sa vie privée comme on l'a fait
souvent pour moi le Georges Pompidou
c'est le c'est le type c'est à dire que
Georges Pompidou à cette image de
banquier
voilà et je pense qu'il a voulu donner
une autre image
au lecteur de match
oui j'ai une maison de campagne oui je
vais en Bretagne car Jacques dans ma
maison oui je vais pêcher la crevette
avec mon épuisette
là il y a un message qui veut donner
donc c'est de la com oui entre le photos
journaliste et la communication il y a
une grosse différence c'est le
commanditaire
la commande était essentielle qui quitte
à commander la photo est-ce que c'est un
journal ou est-ce que c'est un politique
ou est-ce que c'est la raison blanche ou
l'Elysée si un jour j'acceptais une
commande de l'Elysée je mettrai
complètement mon logiciel je serais plus
du tout j'essaierai plus du tout de
chercher cet espace
ce petit espace de liberté qui me reste
dans tout ce dispositif mais bon j'irai
faire des images assez flatteuses pour
le
pour le gars pour le gars qui me qui me
plaît quoi
[Musique]
je m'appelle Jean-Claude coutos j'ai une
quarantaine d'années de reportages
photographiques derrière moi pas mal de
reportages international mais aussi
beaucoup de photographies politiques
pour Libération dans les années 80 et
pour le monde depuis 16 ans
[Musique]
pourquoi tu fais de la photo
j'ai fait la photo
peut-être parce que je sais pas c'est
bien dessiné
dans ma province
moi qui rêvait de notre métier où on
roule en voiture de sport ou on fait le
tour du monde et toujours accompagné de
jolies filles bon à l'époque au milieu
des années 70 reporter photographe il y
avait rien de plus sexy quoi
[Musique]
comme tu accompagnes le président de la
République
mais le but c'est de sortir du des
cordons quoi et de s'approcher de plus
près du personnage qu'on suit et pour ça
les 30 ans les 30 années précédentes
m'ont
beaucoup appris puisque je considère que
la désobéissance c'est une des
principales qualités du photojournaliste
est-ce que tu peux te présenter ouais je
suis Sébastien Calvet je suis
photographe et éditeur photo je j'ai
travaillé successivement à Libération au
site les jours.fr et aujourd'hui je suis
à Mediapart pour moi la photographie
aprèste un prétexte à vivre des choses à
rencontrer des gens
que je n'aurais pas rencontré et des
lieux où je ne serai pas allé si j'avais
pas eu un appareil photo autour du cou
[Musique]
je crois qu'on est photographe et on
fait de la photographie de manière
générale avec tout ce qu'on est et tout
ce qu'on aime et j'aime l'abstraction et
j'aime la politique donc j'essaie de
faire se rencontrer des deux
c'est un photographe qui a ce talent de
se dire je vais mettre un autre endroit
d'ailleurs sur les photos de Calvet on
voit souvent les autres photographes
cette photo de François Hollande qui
saute de la tribune c'est une magnifique
photo politique
[Musique]
on est à Tulle en Corrèze au soir du
premier tour de la présidentielle 2012
moi je couvre toute la campagne pour
Libération le premier tour représente
une sanction du quinquennat qui s'achève
François Hollande donc je connais quand
même un petit peu le bonhomme par des
gestes des regards et c'est plutôt
quelqu'un qui est en capacité de
déborder le protocole et la sécurité si
il voit quelqu'un de l'autre côté de la
rue qui l'intéresse et qu'il a envie
d'aller dire bonjour il va traverser la
rue et quand il a fini son discours je
vois qu'il fait à son officier de
sécurité qu'on voit sur le côté il fait
comme ça
et là je comprends qu'il va sauter de la
tribune en fait et j'entends à ce moment
là l'équipe de François Hollande qui
fait non François non
et je déclenche plusieurs fois puis là
il part faire un bain de fou là je me
fais complètement déborder par les gens
autour de moi mais en fait je sais que
je m'en fous que je vais plus faire de
photos parce que je sais que c'est ça la
photo et je pars directement transmettre
cette photo qui qui va apparaître dans
le journal le lendemain et
l'air de rien si ce réceptionne mal
c'est pas non plus un grand sportif si
ce réceptionne mal et qui se foutent une
cheville ou pète une jambe il reste
quand même 15 jours de campagne pour
aller vers le deuxième tour ce serait
quand même pas le meilleur de moments
pour pour se péter un pied j'en ai
discuté avec François Hollande
où je lui dis mais quand même c'était
quand même un peu inconscient de sauter
de cette tribune à ce moment-là et là il
m'arrête il me dit non non vous dites
que je saute mais je saute pas moi je
m'envole
[Musique]
quel est le premier président que tu
aies pris en photo agiss car
Giscard j'étais au service cinéma des
armées
20 ans
la première fois que je photographie
aussi la première parution je crois dans
le magazine de l'armée qui s'appelait
Tamer moi j'ai grandi comme ça de Gaulle
Pompidou avec les images très strictes
très figées très institutionnel Giscard
sortait de ça quoi donc voilà après je
lui ai vu le jour où je l'ai vu de près
je me suis
souvienne de cette image oui quand il
avance devant les troupes mais aussi à
un moment j'ai pu l'approcher parce que
c'était une époque où pouvait accrocher
n'importe quel homme politique y compris
un président de très près faire le tour
photographié peut-être trois flics qui
te prenaient un qui te bousculé qui te
ramené vers un vers un carré presse non
non ça c'était je me souviens que bon ce
gars était grand
[Musique]
c'était la première fois que je voyais
un président ouais c'était c'était le
moment
[Musique]
ça c'est une photo j'aime beaucoup parce
que c'est il y a aussi ce qu'on appelle
la solitude du président donc là c'est
Giscard donc là il a reçu mage il donne
une grande interview politique mais pour
illustrer ça on a un Giscard qui est en
train de lire un papier dans les jardins
de l'Élysée très belle photo
et là en train d'annoter en train de
prendre des notes quelque part il pose
pas enfin il pose pas
c'est une fausse pose évidemment il sait
que le photographe est là mais voilà il
est pas plan devant l'objectif
donc ça c'est une grande
oui c'est sur 8 pages interview
ce que j'espère il a changé d'image en
cours de mandat
parce qu'il arrive avec une espèce de
modernité incroyable il fait des
réformes
c'est exactement ça c'est un mélange
parce que c'était ça a été un grand
président quand même qu'il a fait bouger
les choses il a il a amené modernité
enfin la majorité à 18 ans
c'est lui tout ça il a il a transformé
vraiment la société française mais tout
en étant dans un habit d'une certaine
bourgeoisie
aristocratie je dirais un peu ce mélange
de ça d'homme il a essayé de donner une
autre image de lui je pense mais son
image de de
raideur de rigueur et rester jusqu'au
bout
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing a pourtant bien
essayé de se démarquer de ses
prédécesseurs
[Musique]
en 1974 sa photo officielle est pensée
comme une rupture mise en musique par le
peintre et photographe Jacques-Henri
lactique il a voulu une photo qui ne
soit pas conventionnelle qui soit plus
jeune que vieille plus gai que triste
comme était ce président lui se voulait
ni dans une attitude trogolienne ni
surtout pas dans un président normal
mais dans un président qui faisait chaud
dans les premières années après ça c'est
un peu compliqué et il s'est un peu figé
mais dans les premières années il
faisait les choses il y avait une
modernité j'avais commencé un peu sous
Pompidou mais là c'est ce drapeau bleu
blanc rouge magnifique une fois que les
présidents arrivent à l'Elysée il pose
pour leur portrait officiel est-ce que
cette photo l'image qui va imposer pour
le futur
moi sincèrement pour ma part ça les
photos tout ça j'ai jamais vraiment
saisi
cette photo au moins c'est quelque chose
de
je dirais pas quatre postale mais
presque c'est je vois pas le message
dedans c'est quand même une photo de
communication de la part de président il
communique ils disent voilà cette tena
en tout cas Giscard on peut dire ça de
François Hollande aussi qui choisit un
photographe
et qui fait une photo très différente de
ce qui a toujours été fait auparavant
oui on est dans les jardins on voit le
bâtiment à gauche un peu de mouvement
puis à gauche on voit il y a dans le
rapport européen qui est
je sais pas c'est c'est
ouais c'est différent mais bon Chirac
elle est c'est la même photo
pratiquement
je me souviens d'ailleurs quand on avait
reçu cette photo
la première chose qu'on voit c'est le
bouton mais voilà non je sais pas c'est
sincèrement quand vous prenez le quand
vous connaissez la personnalité de
Chirac est-ce que cette photo là
vous dites bah voilà ça c'est Chirac non
quand Bettina Reims immortalise Jacques
Chirac pour ce portrait officiel qui
restera 12 ans dans toutes les mairies
de France elle choisit pour cadre les
jardins de l'Elysée
un portrait réalisé en à peine 20
minutes de celui qu'elle dit voir comme
un cowboy
est-ce que tu te souviens du premier
président de la République que tu es
photographié oui c'était Jacques Chirac
j'ai voulu être photographe depuis que
j'ai 12 ans donc c'était j'en avais à
cette époque 25 j'arrivais à l'Élysée et
donc c'était impression d'aller à cet
endroit là mais en plus quand Chirac est
arrivé et que je l'ai vu dans le viseur
de mon appareil photo ça m'a encore plus
impressionné à ce moment là je me suis
dit ah ça y est en fait parce qu'on peut
regarder plein d'images on peut regarder
plein de travaux de photographe mais
quand on est soi-même dans une situation
où la personne que vous connaissez que
vous avez vu à la télé depuis des années
des années que vous avez l'impression de
connaître un petit moment elle se
retrouve dans le viseur de votre
appareil photo et alors là la liaison
elle est très très différente après ce
qui est sûr c'est que j'ai
refortographié Jacques Chirac après
plusieurs fois
jusqu'à sa mort et
c'est compliqué parce que Jacques Chirac
c'était déjà
c'était presque un dessin à lui seul
c'est quelque chose de le personnage
correspondait vraiment à sa caricature
alors ça c'est une de mes photos
préférées de Jacques Chirac là il est
premier ministre on est dans la timidité
du pouvoir et il a effectué une sorte de
tour du monde en concorde et la visiter
je sais pas combien de pays c'est une
sorte de record
c'est une photo politique parce que elle
montre
elle insignification on peut même dire
une signification politique c'est un ça
montre la décontraction d'un homme ou la
concentration d'un homme il se repose
une photo par définition qui est
destinée à la presse à une légende sur
cette photo de Jacques Chirac on va vous
en donner les circonstances donc s'il se
rend à une réunion importante une
rencontre avec un chef d'État c'est
important de le montrer dans quel état
il se trouve à ce moment-là alors
évidemment est-ce qu'il dort vraiment
est-ce que cette photo est posée ou pas
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas voilà
c'est une posture
tout à fait la Chirac les mains sur le
ventre en train de faire la sieste alors
peut-être quand même que
c'est une sorte de composition parce
qu'il existe la même photo sans le
masque mais en tout cas ça me donne
cette photo là qui fait partie de ces
photos qui rendent le personnage
sympathique oui effectivement c'est
toujours l'image qu'il a voulu donner de
lui
et je dis l'image qu'il a voulu donner
lui parce que c'est pas complètement son
image c'est pas que ça c'est pas l'image
qu'il avait à l'époque où il était
président on disait que c'était un
feignant on disait que c'était un escroc
des écoles voilà si on était en état à
mon avis dans un excès un excès inverse
et alors toi en tant que photographe
qu'est-ce que tu vas raconter qu'est-ce
que tu vas montrer moi ce que je vais
raconter c'est exactement ce que je
pense du personnage
[Musique]
je vais venir vous voir avec des photos
politiques de personnages politiques qui
eux se montrent beaucoup plus
alors peuple que vous et je suis venu
avec un paquet de photos et il y avait
toutes Chirac qui était à côté et il y
avait des photos très très belles et
très étonnante de de grands personnages
du moment qu'en bas de chef avec sa
femme Margaret Thatcher qui qui faisait
la cuisine etc etc et puis de pêche à la
crevette Giscard faisant du SMIC et
toujours avec la famille autour et je
vais vous monsieur le Président oui on a
des photos de vous mais par exemple
votre petit-fils personne le connaît et
c'est ma vie privée je veux pas montrer
à être et c'est qu'un jour trois
semaines après clope Chirac m'appelle le
président est d'accord mais on va faire
une une opération avec un photographe au
Fort de Brégançon Jacques Chirac
descendait avec son petit-fils et le
photographe était pas très loin et
prenez des photos
et ça a donné de très très belles photos
le titre de match était Chirac
grand-père et on le voit avec ses
baskets improbables et puis son son
petit-fils sur les genoux c'était une
belle image puis après il se promène
donc voyez on peut c'est pas mentir que
que de faire ça n'est vrai qu'il devait
avoir ce genre de rapport avec son tiers
sont
15 ans après la fin de son mandat quelle
image gardons-nous vraiment de Jacques
Chirac
[Musique]
un grand père un homme politique un des
boulonnable qui semble avoir traversé la
Cinquième République malgré les affaires
[Musique]
un amateur d'art ou bien un type sympa
lié à jamais à l'histoire du Salon de
l'Agriculture et c'est la caricature
totale et en même temps là c'était une
caricature un peu fanée quoi c'était
fatigué il commençait à être malade il
est du mal à se déplacer il semble
l'agriculture c'est un des pires trucs à
photographier c'est à dire que c'est il
y a énormément de monde on passe d'un
stand à l'autre on passe plus de temps
essayer de se faire une place que
vraiment cadrer quelque chose donc
on essaie de faire des images dans les
trous de souris et là on voyait bien au
fur et à mesure qu'il avançait que
c'était très très difficile qu'il était
très très diminué très fatigué il met la
main sur l'épaule de Christian Jacob
avec Bruno Le Maire à côté et c'est un
moment assez émouvant parce qu'il
voulait être là donc voilà moi j'ai
essayé de photographier ce moment
très désordonné
avec une sécurité en panique comme on
voit au premier plan et puis ce Chirac
qui marche vraiment à petit pas et dont
on sent quand même le crépuscule donc
c'était c'est la dernière photo de
Chirac que tu as fait
je pense ouais je pense et est-ce que du
coup c'est l'image que tu gardes de lui
c'est une des images que je garde de lui
mais
après moi j'ai pas énormément
photographier parce que je me suis
intéressé
à des politiques de génération qui
venaient vraiment derrière et encore une
fois c'était un moment où on changeait
l'époque quoi on passe des Chirac à
Sarkozy on change de génération on
change d'époque on change de personnel
politique
on change de manière de style de voilà
tout ça donc
c'est très très différent et
une photo vraiment charnière en tout cas
pour moi c'est une photo charnière on
passe à autre chose quoi on va passer à
autre chose et on le sent donc
évidemment c'est assez
c'est assez touchant
[Musique]
et quelle image vous gardez de François
Mitterrand
a beaucoup de
la silhouette avec le chapeau est-ce que
c'est la photo avec elle mutcall avec un
petit encart de qu'est-ce qu'on garde
c'est la première fois qu'on a dans
l'époque moderne un président de la
République qui reste 14 ans
donc en 14 ans d'abord on le voit
vieillir on le voit atteint dans la
maladie c'est la première fois aussi que
on découvre que le président a une
petite fille qui s'est dévoilée par la
presse donc c'est une succession de
première donc faut choisir des images du
président qui marque cette période
plutôt qu'une seule
quelques mois avant la fin de son
septennat une photo de paparazzi publiée
dans Paris Match va profondément marquer
l'image de François Mitterrand
[Musique]
là je pense on n'est pas dans la com
c'est pas une fausse par hasard c'est
une vraie paparazzade mais
disons que peut-être
que au moment où il sort
le restaurant ou il a l'habitude de
déjeuner avec Mazarine mais il arrive
avant il arrive après ou c'est l'inverse
mais ils sont jamais ensemble là
tout d'un coup ça dure quelques minutes
ils sortent tous les deux et mettez en
je crois pose la main
et là il y a un photographe
donc là ça arrive un match
et là on rentre dans sa vie privée par
une paparazzle la Sérot j'étais rond qui
est aux commandes à l'époque il y a deux
façons de le présenter il y a la façon
je dirais s'il existait voici Closer
en pleine page couverture
et là Roger Terron a fait vraiment
très astucieux sur cette cette
couverture il m'est un portrait de
François Mitterrand gros plan serré et
une fenêtre où on voit cette photo
c'est toujours compliqué parce que en
tout cas c'est une information
[Musique]
je passe pas que les gens soient en
droit de savoir en tout cas c'est
l'information qui arrive donc
je sais pas en tout cas les la photo
existe le problème c'est savoir si on la
montre au bas quoi c'est ça c'est ça
c'est pas mon domaine moi j'ai pas j'ai
pas eu jamais voulu
rentrer dans ce genre de considération
je pense que j'ai fait une fois de la
planque parce que j'étais tout jeune et
puis je me cherchais et puis on m'avait
dit sapé beaucoup et puis il y a le
presse qu'on sort de Hollande qui est
qui est enfermé dans un hôpital
psychiatrique
en Suisse et où j'avais passé je m'étais
fondu dans les au milieu des fous quoi
avec avec mes appareils photos et où
j'avais réussi à avoir la photo et
effectivement ça m'avait rapportera
apporté beaucoup d'argent
mais en me disant je me disais bon moi
c'était pas j'étais pas monté à Paris
pour ça quoi mais vrai pas par hasard
qu'on a défini ça
c'est donc une photo qui est totalement
volée et ça correspond à une scène que
vous-même que vous ne voulez pas montrer
ça c'est un peu la définition alors
cette appliqué beaucoup sur des
personnages people les stars starlette
de cinéma etc en politique beaucoup
moins parce que c'est pas la nature de
du traitement de la politique
en 2014 une vraie paparazade surprend le
président Hollande sur un scooter alors
qu'il rejoint Julie Gayet
avec cette une closer double ses ventes
et c'est une déflagration pour l'image
du président
est-ce que je l'aurai publié elle est
intéressante cette photographie
c'est un président en exercice qui prend
ce risque de se balader en scooter avec
un casque pour retrouver une amie de
coeur
donc c'est lui qui se met dans cette
situation
est-ce qu'il faut la montrer on dit
toujours que le respect mais ça c'est
pour tout le monde
ça s'arrête à la porte de la maison pour
ne pas dire à la porte de la chambre
mais là on est dans un lieu public en
scooter président de la République oui
je vous réponds
sur son scooter c'est il faut toujours
valide
sur son scooter c'est est-ce que
en tout cas si tu l'info en tout cas on
peut pas dire que ça a pas été reçu
comme une info on a parlé pendant
quelque chose qu'on savait pas et qu'on
sait et qu'on s'est d'un coup comme ça
évidemment le problème c'est que la
communication politique c'est c'est
à très bien compris très bien analysé et
c'est complètement approprié toutes ces
codes de cette photographie là
aujourd'hui quand un politique vous
ouvre la porte quand vous rentrez en
fait les trucs sont quand même assez
organisés à organiser ça veut pas dire
que on a mis des comédiens à droite à
gauche mais vous avez un communicant qui
a checké que là il y avait rien de
gênant de problématique comment on est
tellement surveillé et qui sont
tellement sous les feux des réseaux
sociaux de
de tout ça que maintenant même quand
vous ouvre la porte sur une réunion dans
un bureau
un peu sceptisé quoi voilà il y a plus
de prise de risque vous savez il y a un
grand photographe
de Magnum qui s'appelle Diego Goldberg
qui a fait d'excellents reportages sur
le président Mitterrand et l'expliqué
justement quel était son rôle et il
disait la vérité c'est que le
chorégraphe c'est Mitterrand je ne fais
que danser au son de l'image qu'il veut
donner de lui
dans un documentaire sur François
Mitterrand Diego Goldberg raconte
d'ailleurs une des photos les plus
marquantes qui les prises du président
et comment celui-ci la sciemment
construite
[Musique]
on marche en silence comme ça et à un
moment donné on arrive à une clairière
et je me suis dit peut-être c'est une
image et
je commence à lui dire est-ce que ce que
peut-être on peut s'arrêter ici et il me
dit mes cours très courant il me dit non
non vous restez là il part
j'entends des bruits comme si quelqu'un
marchait sur l'eau et
j'essaye de voir d'où ça vient le son
et je vois qu'il y a une ruisseau en bas
et à ma surprise qu'est-ce que je vois
au fond du ruisseau il vient
il marche sur l'eau avec ses bottes
jaunes sauf la rouge son manteau chapeau
et c'est une je crois pas à mes yeux je
descends
tu changes d'optique parce qu'il était
loin je prends un long objectif et j'ai
fait 400 images donner surpris et en
même temps heureux parce que je me rends
compte que c'est une image vraiment
extraordinaire inhabituelle de voir un
président de la République faisant ça et
voilà ces images
en fait je crois que c'est lui qui l'a
construit cette image
c'est au début de son mandat c'est une
façon de dire
voilà ce que je suis
l'homme grave sérieux solitaire je crois
qu'il voulait surtout ça
[Musique]
en 2007 quand Nicolas Sarkozy arrive au
pouvoir il décide de créer une image
très éloignée de celle de ses
prédécesseurs
pour le faire il choisit Philippe Varin
un photographe plus habitué des peoples
que des politiques puisqu'il est entre
autres le photographe officiel de la
Star Academy
[Musique]
voilà les deux pardon Gisèle Freud mais
ça c'est un choix de fidélité
avec le couple il avait une proximité
professionnelle aussi avec Cécilia et là
la photo
le plus étonnant c'est quand même le
choix de Sarkozy de retourner
dans la bibliothèque avec ce portrait
qui pour moi est le moins réussi de tous
parce qu'il y a en fait le personnage
est posé devant cette bibliothèque
de manière un peu étrangère
ces deux drapeaux sont beaucoup trop
grands il y a le reflet sur la reliure
du livre qui est totalement collé au
visage de qui pour moi en matière l'oeil
tout de suite
c'est vraiment une panne copie de ce qui
a pu être fait en termes de photos
officielle dans la bibliothèque et
vraiment vraiment pas réussi je connais
pas Varin et j'ai pas de grief mais
là alors après ça correspond à ce qui
s'est passé dans le mandat c'est à dire
que c'est plein de gants c'est bling
bling c'est effectivement c'est un peu
c'est des Pogues de la téléréalité
c'est déjà à Philippe Varin qu'il avait
confié son affiche de campagne
et c'est encore lui qui immortalisera la
famille Sarkozy le jour de
l'intronisation
et ce genre d'homme politique il va au
plus court efficace rapide
et la confiance
hier pour le cliché qui sera dans toutes
les mairies et bâtiments officielles la
séance de pose a duré 20 minutes chrono
je sais qu'avec lui il faut travailler
vite parce que pose il vous donne tout
ce que vous voulez mais c'est très court
je sais qu'il aimait la bibliothèque qui
voulait le drapeau français
voilà on lui a proposé par rapport
européen de trouver que c'était une très
bonne idée et voilà comment la photo
c'est c'est monté on l'a beaucoup
reproché par exemple à Nicolas Sarkozy
d'avoir rendu cette sa fonction tropele
en posant dans le bureau avec Carla
Bruni ou quand il était à la mairie de
Neuilly là c'était vraiment inspiré de
John Kennedy avec son fils qui était
sous le bureau voilà
il y a eu beaucoup de reproches mais
c'est pas lui qui a inventé ça
c'est Georges Pompidou
on sort du général de Gaulle avec son
épouse Yvonne ont toujours 3 mètres
derrière avec son petit sac et là tout
d'un coup Claude Pompidou elle est là
elle est omniprésente c'est comme
Kennedy avec Jacky Kennedy c'est presque
un étendard sa femme l'élégance les
fameux tout le monde veut s'habiller
tout le monde veut se coiffer comme
Jackie Kennedy donc il se sert de ça
[Musique]
pour atteindre la présidence Nicolas
Sarkozy a compris très tôt l'intérêt de
mettre en avant sa vie personnelle
familiale et surtout sa femme Cécilia
en 2005 comme un boomerang il paye le
prix de cette exposition
match publie sa une photo de Cécilia en
compagnie de Richard Attias son amant le
journal atteint des records de vente au
mois de mai 2005
on apprend que Cécilia Sarkozy et
Nicolas Sarkozy un problème une
séparation le premier le ministre de
l'Intérieur pardon ce qui n'est pas
président à l'époque le dit lui-même aux
Français oui j'ai un problème de couple
comme certains Français peuvent avoir
des millions de familles la mienne a
connu des difficultés ces difficultés
nous sommes en train de les surmonter et
ce que je dois en dire plus je ne pense
pas le fait d'avoir mis en avant le rôle
de votre femme depuis longtemps à vos
côtés dans votre carrière elle est aussi
votre chef de cabinet et donc d'avoir
effacé en partie la frontière vie
publique vie privée est-ce que ça vous
expose pas forcément à ce type de
réaction bien sûr c'est ça fait je ne
suis pas le premier à travailler avec
son épouse je lui dois énormément
Cécilia compte beaucoup pour moi chacun
le sait je crois que la réciproque est
également vrai mais je ne pense pas que
cela mérite qu'on dise des choses la
plupart du temps d'ailleurs inexactes
qui lui manque beaucoup de respect qui
la font souffrir toute la presse
française mais aussi mondiale sans part
du sujet je me souviens de de grandes
enquêtes dans dans l'Obs ou dans
magazine Elle ou autre qui parlait de un
grand portrait de cécis à Sarkozy elle a
choisi l'amour plutôt que le pouvoir
enfin bref c'est là quoi on passe en été
donc c'est la rubrique de l'été et match
qui est un journal qui est écrit
beaucoup avec la photographie le taxe
est plutôt derrière on sait pas trop
quoi faire mais on a plein de photos qui
arrivent sans arrêt
de paparazzi ou de photographes qui
photographie Cécilia Sarkozy et Richard
Athias et
eux-mêmes se mettent dans la situation
d'être photographiée c'est à dire quand
il loue une voiture décapotable il
s'expose donc ces photos là ils arrivent
toutes les semaines ils arrivent à
marche et on ne publie pas et à un
moment donc on est en septembre donc
après après les vacances on a
l'information que le somme des Times a
acheté une série de photos et faire ça
une dans les dans quelques jours et là
on décide de tout casser de mettre cette
photo Nicolas Sarkozy ne supporte pas de
voir s'écrouler une image patiemment
construite
il connaît bien le propriétaire de Paris
Match Arnaud Lagardère et demande alors
le départ du directeur de la rédaction
il l'obtient
alain Genestar devra démissionner
ironie de l'histoire Pascal rostin le
paparazzi responsable de cette fameuse
photo est un ami de Carla Bruni et
quelques mois plus tard il prendra cette
image du couple dans le bureau de
l'Élysée
je sais pas ce que c'est une stature
présidentielle j'ai du mal à le définir
en tout cas quand Sarkozy arrive à
l'Elysée en 2007 il était mise à
l'intérieur et avec en éclipsant à peu
près tous les autres membres du
gouvernement avant il a conquis l'UMP il
a fait quand même l'Union toutes les
droites il arrive
mardi de pouvoir et
il puissant
est-ce que ça donne une stature
présidentielle
c'est difficile à dire on voyait un
homme politique qui était un peu comment
dirais-je soit fanfaron soit sautillant
et là on a vu un président de la
République agissant
c'est les événements qui font le qui
déclenche justement la dimension donc
c'est la grande crise économique
financière donc c'est 2008 on a vu que
toute cette énergie ça pouvait mobiliser
l'Europe avec Merkel tout ça et vraiment
fait des choses et le deuxième événement
c'est la crise en Géorgie ou là c'est
pareil il prend une stature
et s'il restait une photo de Nicolas
Sarkozy
ce que je viens de dire sur les deux
crises internationales il y a pas
vraiment d'image ou sur des images
figées
c'est plutôt une photo de lui
cette volonté de toujours se faire
photographier en train de courir en
train de faire du vélo en train de
monter les marches de l'Elysée et c'est
tout à fait lui ça c'est et je crois
qu'il aimait se faire photographier
comme ça là
typiquement cette image de Sarkozy elle
a l'air de rien comme ça mais elle est
historique on est le premier jour de du
mandat de Nicolas Sarkozy le lendemain
de la passion de pouvoir et on est dans
le dans la cour de Elysée c'est le
perron de l'Elysée et on a des espèces
des coups de fil à des confrères
photographes et on apprend que en fait
il est parti faire le fameux footing
avec François Fillon dans le bois de
Boulogne et puis d'un coup on entend les
sirènes du cortège présidentiel qui
arrive et là on sait tous regardé en se
disant mais ils vont pas nous déposer au
milieu de la cour comme ça et en fait si
on a vu le cortège arriver au milieu de
la cour présidentielle
la porte s'ouvrir et le président partir
en petite foulée et monter les marches
quatre à quatre pour rentrer dans Elysée
et une fois qu'on a fait cette série de
photons on s'est regardé en se disant
mais c'est complètement incroyable c'est
la première photo d'un président en
exercice sur les marches du Péron de
l'Élysée en short tennis
et alors il a le total look Nike avec la
Breitling et Blackberry à l'époque ils
n'ont jamais refait pour le coup les
communicants n'ont pas remis en scène
cette image tout le reste du mandat
parce que je pense qu'il y avait une
petite petite limite nous on a fait à
Libération on a une avec cette photo
quelques jours après
voilà et c'est anecdotique et en même
temps ça correspond bien à ce qui était
le personnage jusqu'à les être aussi
encore une fois
son mandat c'est-à-dire la volonté de
casser les codes de la présidence se
démarquer totalement de Chirac
voilà sur un mandat vieillissant et
finissant et ça correspondait à la
campagne mener mener à vitesse gambée et
quelle image il reste aujourd'hui de
Nicolas Sarkozy
quelqu'un très efficace au niveau des
médias au niveau des aussi de l'image
qu'il a donné
et nous a énormément offert enfin au
lecteur je parle alors par contre
Pompidou lui il a voulu changer son
image Sarkozy il a révolution du tout je
suis une que ça Sarkozy je suis comme je
suis voilà comme ça s'il devait rester
une photo
Nicolas Sarkozy
c'est vrai que j'aime beaucoup
c'est vrai que la photo quand même de
Rostand dans le bureau présidentielle
avec elle assise sur l'accoudoir il y a
une photo que j'aime bien aussi de
Nicolas Sarkozy et là je dirais presque
elle est presque naturelle il est assis
à son bureau il en chemise et il a le
téléphone vous savez que tu vois quand
vous parlez puis vous mettez le
téléphone comme ça voilà en attente vous
le posez sur l'épaule et puis ça c'est
une photo que j'aime bien parce qu'elle
est
elle est très naturelle
il y a une photo très naturelle de
Nicolas Sarkozy c'est quand il est avec
François Hollande un match
qui a été fait pour nous c'est ça se
passe dans les studios de photos dans
les locaux de match ils sont pas encore
candidats à tous les deux ils sont on
les a fait venir tous les deux pour
commenter la société française
François Hollande
ce qu'il faut savoir enfin les gens le
savent il est très drôle on les met en
place voilà éclairage en règle sur tous
les deux comme ça puis à coup il
commence à se parler et puis là ils
éclate de rire tous les deux
et là c'est une photo magique
ce qui restera à l'apparition c'est les
deux hommes
sérieux qui regardent puis après on a
passé tout le mekinov quoi et là on voit
ces photos il rigole tous les deux et
c'est je pense c'est ces photos là qui
restent dans l'histoire c'est quand ils
éclatent de rire tous les deux
la complicité ne durera que le temps
d'un cliché
quelques années plus tard alors qu'ils
se font face pour la présidentielle de
2012 François Hollande prend le
contre-pied du président sortant et joue
la carte de la normalité
moi président de la République
j'essaierai d'avoir de la hauteur de jus
pour fixer les grandes orientations les
grandes impulsions mais en même temps je
ne m'occuperai pas de tout et j'aurai
toujours le souci de la proximité avec
les Français j'avais évoqué
présidente normale rien n'est normal
quand on est président de la République
Nicolas Sarkozy avait choisi le
Fouquet's pour célébrer sa victoire
françois Hollande fait un choix bien
différent il a promis une forme de
normalité proche des gens alors c'est
sur la place de tulle que le candidat
tout juste élu offre sa première image
c'est un truc à pas raté quand tu quand
tu cours une campagne c'est bien c'est
bien la dernière photo c'est la photo de
la victoire d'abord il faut il faut
s'arranger pour être derrière le
vainqueur ou ou celle qui a gagné
et surtout pas rater cette cette image
qui va forcément être utilisée par le
journal pour lequel tu travailles le
lendemain a eu ou en très grande à la
page etc bref il était là pour ça tu es
là pour pas rater cette image alors
j'étais là ce soir là et c'était un
moment un peu compliqué ça a pas été
moi j'ai pas des très bonnes photos sur
ce moment-là
mes lumières est pourrie le moment est
pourri il y a trop de monde je pense que
tous on n'a pas des images
hypersatisfaisantes de ce moment-là
après le vote le matin je sais que je
suis resté pendant 11 heures sur un
praticable
au pouvoir d'arroser un abattoir le
changement c'est maintenant je suis
parti un peu dans la foule pour faire
deux trois photos des gens puis je suis
retourné là à attendre cette image moi
j'ai pas eu la bonne place à ce
moment-là j'avais décidé d'être devant
sur les voilà sur le premier rang sur
les barrières et puis à un moment j'ai
vu des membres du service date du Parti
socialiste disparaître et être remplacé
par des policiers et ça change ça
participe pour changement de statut
évidemment et où on se dit ah ben là on
s'appartient plus en fait cette image
c'est le miracle c'est un miracle parce
que ils sont arrivés il y a eu cette
aire d'accordéon il y a eu ces pas de
danse etc
[Musique]
le vers 2h 3h du matin j'ai commencé à
retrimer
cette image qui alors elle était
parfaitement éclairée pourquoi parce que
tu as
tu as un flash qui monte de la foule
comme ça ça se drapeau qui se baladait
mais tu as cette terre comme ça de très
hollywoodienne de Valérie et le
lendemain la photo paraît en Une du
journal comme ça en pleine page la
semaine suivante j'ai reçu un coup de
fil d'une communicante proche du couple
présidentiel qui m'a dit vous savez le
président aime beaucoup votre image ah
bon moi c'était la première fois que tu
avais que j'avais une un contact comme
ça avec le avec le pouvoir
et alors ils aimeraient bien tirage etc
bon
alors je savais pas trop s'il fallait en
faire un grand tirage un petit tirage
finalement j'ai fait un grand tirage un
petit tirage et j'ai su très très vite
que le petit tirage elle s'est retrouvé
encadrée dans le bureau de Valérie trier
et le grand était sur la cheminée du
président
qui est resté longtemps jusqu'au jour où
il y a eu cette affaire du scooter la
séparation du couple en plein été on
fait un il accorde un interview au Monde
on se retrouve dans son bureau j'ai dit
mais je suis content de savoir qu'elle
est toujours là quoi
[Musique]
c'est la photo de la victoire etc voilà
moi de 15 jours après
sortez le livre de evaler très régulière
ou là la photo elle a disparu de la
cheminée
et après je l'imaginais j'imaginais ma
photo dans un carton on a les sous-sol
de l'Élysée tu vois voilà quoi
le jour de l'investiture Jean-Claude
couteau photographie le président qui
remonte les Champs-Élysées sous la pluie
[Musique]
il est trempé
cette image le poursuivra tout son
mandat
[Musique]
mais François Hollande assume il veut
donner l'image d'un homme normal
[Musique]
il confie d'ailleurs son portrait
officiel à Raymond Depardon
un photographe à la carrière immense
connu entre autres pour son travail sur
la ruralité et la vie ordinaire le
portrait fait parler
beaucoup le jugera
[Musique]
en photographie et qui déteste poser moi
je les photographié trois quatre fois
dans des portraits posés il aime pas ça
il n'aime pas ça il pense à autre chose
il est ailleurs ça n'intéresse pas il
est beaucoup plus intéressant à
photographier dans une dynamique quand
il passe
donc
non non moi je crois pas que ce portrait
raté il correspond à un moment à quelque
chose à un personnage
elle est fidèle au personnage ouais je
crois
je crois quand on choisit un monde de
pardon
on choisit
des plus grands photographes français et
documentariste
en activité c'est de travailler sur les
paysans c'est
le travail sur la politique sur la
France depuis des années des années donc
il y a quand même quelque chose qui est
qui a du sens voilà
ce qu'il aime pas ce qu'il est mou ce
qu'il aime bien disent qu'il est juste
il reste pas une image figée de lui oui
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est ce qui m'a fait dire qu'il était
plutôt c'était quelqu'un de simple et de
mais est-ce qu'il en restera dans 10 ans
est-ce qu'il restera une image de
Hollande
non mais en disant c'est comme c'est
comme ceux qui
ce qui à la mort de Chirac qui était qui
était
justement nostalgie que des années
Chirac c'était les mêmes qui allaient
qui allaient voter Chirac avec une épée
lalène sur le sur le nez c'est le
problème c'est pas forcément l'image du
Président c'est ce qu'on était nous-même
il y a 10 ans
c'était mieux parce que elle était plus
jeune etc etc voilà ça et
Hollande aussi c'est trop tôt il y aura
des nostalgiques des années des années
Hollande comme il y a des nostalgiques
maintenant des en Chirac quoi
en 2014 un visage est de plus en plus
présent dans l'œil des photographes
Emmanuel Macron vient alors d'être nommé
ministre de l'économie
[Musique]
on a une sortie Conseil des ministres et
François Hollande sort pour vraiment
faire une faire une image avec avec
Emmanuel Macron c'est vraiment ici comme
s'il le présentait à tout le monde
regardait
il descend les marches comme ça et en
fait c'est lui qui tient le bras de
Michel Sapin en fait il prend les rênes
c'est à dire que tout de suite il se
laisse pas prendre le bras il reprend le
bras de Michel Sapin et c'est lui qui
dirige et je me suis dit voilà assez
rapidement en fait on s'est rendu compte
que le type était était en train de la
créature était en train de leur échapper
quoi
[Musique]
il reste un peu moins de 5 ans à
Emmanuel Macron pour s'isoler son image
de président
[Musique]
il pourra choisir le cadre
la lumière
le temps d'exposition peut être
mais il y aura toujours quelque chose
qui lui échappera
[Musique]
et quand le temps l'aura patiné
nous pourrons enfin savoir
quelle image il aura laissé
[Musique]